there's taiwan walker still looking for
that elusive first win since the
all-star break numbers for the entire
season against the fills though he
started four times this year and the
mets have won three of them and he is
having himself an mvp caliber year and a
curved ball lifted out to left mcneil
leads his back has room on the warning
track and he puts it away to retire the
sides tonight is the eighth start that
wheeler is making against his former
team he's made 63 starts at city field
during his career
swag and a miss and a high heater one
god here in the first and here's brandon
nimmo just off the injured list today
swag and a
how about the movement on that pitch jt
romuto will lead off here in inning
number two no score
one two and a swing and a little floater
into right it'll fall for a base hit jt
real muto again didn't hit it hard but
he puts it in the right place and he's
got the first hit of the game
one two
outside he's going the throw is wide
jt's got a stolen base he's in scoring
position that's number 12.
didi slices one to left
attack mcneal is under it makes the
catch jt's going to third the throw to
third off wide
well let's see if the phillies can get a
run here that'll give freddie galvez a
chance
freddie hits it out towards center field
going back on it is nimbo it'll be deep
enough to score real muto nimo makes the
catch here comes jt the phillies
manufacture a run here in the second and
take a one-nothing lead is michael
conforto conforto hitting 227 this
season strike three caught on the
outside quarter
three strikeouts for zach wheeler and
that'll bring up javier baez
hopped up
back of first
tough spot miller is there in a snow
cone
how about that what flavor vanilla
here comes james mccann
mccann
hitting 236. this season
strike three called at the knees and
mccann is going to say something to the
home plate up fire because his pitcher
he doesn't think is getting
those pitches but that's four strikeouts
for wheeler hey
vr had no chance in that first bat
against his fastball
what are the chances he goes first pitch
fastball then everything else you're
going to see off speed
swag in a miss he got him with a slider
five strikeouts for wheeler through
three innings of work tonight
rounded out to third bases first time up
and segura hits one off the foot of
walker to flash right to lindor who
throws him out
his save and a beauty that's a second
assist the redirect
by walker for the 1-6-3 beautiful
assist last 64 games 356 with 19 home
runs
that one's out toward right center field
nimbo's going back and he can't get it
it's a one hop
into his glove and harper extends his
hitting streak he's at second base
his 37th double three and two on rio
muto beltai set from walker swinging a
missed strike three good pitch
slider at jt real muto chasing second
strikeout for taiwan and a big one two
outs with harper still at second
tap to the left side charging vr quick
throw high but alonso able to stay on
the bag harper never slowed down coming
around third
so that was a big stretch by alonso to
make sure his foot didn't come off get
their first one tonight here in the
fourth it comes leading off and lindor
coming up one nothing phillies
swag and a miss he got a couple swings
and misses on that pitch with lindor and
six k's for zach wheeler and that loads
him up for baez first walk given up by
wheeler and the mets have their shot not
going to get too many shots against zach
so you better take advantage of them
when you do oh and one to javi
and he bloops one to right field that's
a base hit
in the score is nemo alonso will stop at
third javi baez goes the other way for
an rbi single to tie up the game at one
base is still loaded still only one out
and the batter is jeff mcneal
and the pitch
out towards center field it's not depot
doubles coming in makes the catch
tagging from third is alonso then he
stops
oh doable got rid of it quickly
there are two outs and james mccann is
the hitter
line drive caught by dede gregorius out
at shortstop
the inning is over
the phillies have sidestepped what could
have been a dangerous fourth inning
so brad miller took out his first time
up brad miller with 18 home runs on the
season
sends one deep to center field forget
about it that's about five rows deep
he's just given the fills a 2-1 lead he
crushed it
19 home runs for miller how's that for
an answer back from the boys huh that
was a beautiful swing
443. he doesn't hit hit cheap once does
he he does not runners on first and
second for new york the trouble that
conforto has had with left-handers this
year and that's why joe brings in the
heart throwing jose alvarado
and that one's hit back toward the
middle should be two dede's got one and
two oh
that works yes it does
so now it's davisol bat with first and
third and two out with the mets down by
a run in the sixth and the two two
swag and a miss he got him
that is some heavy lifting from jose
alvarado
so now the rookie fearling comes up with
the basis full
fly ball right field conforto's under it
tagging it third is dede conforto's got
it he's gonna throw to the plate here
comes gregorius the throw not in time
it's a sac fly and the phil's add one
it's a 3-1 game
first and second two outs
says the third base umpire i think
somebody's going to get run i think oh
man joe joe is hot wow i'm assuming it
was joe that was thrown out i don't know
if it would have been anybody else but
he's got out number one
one out one on vr the battery's over for
three
swinging a ground ball deep short diving
deed he's got it throws behind him to
second and a pick by segura what a play
between dede and gene segura didi threw
it blindly behind him as he was lying
down on the ground and threw a perfect
strike to segura who stretched and
received the throw for the out that is
as fancy a play as you will see an
infielder make and how about the stretch
by gene at second is a no-look pass
to perfection
two men down now finish it off
fly ball center field oh duple's on the
run he's going to track it down
and the inning is over
two outs here in the eighth inning and
dede is coming up
a little floater out towards center
field that's going to drop in for a hit
a runo score segura goes to third
bobbled by nimmo the throw to second not
in time
it's a 4-1 game
without
slices one down the left field line and
that's a fair ball bouncing into the
corner when door will score then forto
into second base with an rbi double and
it's four to two
and the mitz will get the tying run to
back
payoff pitch
swinging a line drive right center field
herrera's after it can't get it he dives
and he knocks it away around there
scoring conforto polar in the second to
throw in time
elar believes he was safe he wants the
mets to check
but after the seventh inning it is up to
the umpires to decide whether to accept
a crew chief review appears that they
will what's it going to be cv safe
so the nuts get the call from the pen
they've gotten 11 so far they have a
one-run lead and the pitch to brandon
nimmo is swung on hitting the air center
field fairly deep herrera at the track
he's got ruby makes the catch and the
ball game is over the phillies get those
12 outs from the pen and they hang on
for a gut-wrenching 4-3 win
you